hello everyone and welcome back to the
season 17 TCC super finally laches zero
versus stockfish this is game 44 in game
43 we already checked out a game where
stockfish had the white pieces and Leela
had to go for the Queen to d6
Scandinavian well my favorite at the
moment weapon against White's eforp so I
was very happy that they were playing
that game and I said that we were gonna
cover the one where Leela had the white
pieces well to see if the even the
opening stands or was it just a very
impressive game by stockfish so stock
which played really a tactical
brilliancy in that game and now let's
see how deal deal Leela deals with it
with the white pieces so II for as in
the previous game d5 captures captures
Knight to c3 and now the retreat to d6
we have Queen to d6 d4 we have Knight to
f6 Knight to f3 and a sixth row
everything the same as in the previous
game g3 it is a up until this moment
that the opening is predefined with the
ship to g4 stock which goes for the same
defenses Leela but in the previous game
you know that stock which went for h3
here but Leo just continues with Bishop
to f4 and that this this move has been
seen before in human games and mostly
when the Queen is under attack you're
gonna play Queen to be for Queen to b6
maybe Queen to d7 those are the known
replies but here we have Quinta ecigs by
starfish with check and it is in fact a
new move so as a move seven we have a
completely new game now it seems that
both allele and stalkerish are showing
us that we've been playing the Queen b6
Scandinavian all wrong this whole time
but it's not all that crazy to give this
check yes you block your pawn here but
how does white defend for example if you
block with the bishop just captures
night and you cannot capture B and due
to the pin blocking with the Queen is
not better if Queen blocks then again
you just capture it and the Queen cannot
recapture so black just wins apiece so
what black needs to do if you don't want
to play something silly like maybe block
with this knight or King b2 is bring
back the Bishop Bishop to e3
okay black lost the temple but also
white lost the temple so not not at all
weird yeah I don't know why sometimes
the TV just starts starts by itself but
yeah Bishop back to III both Leela and
stalkerish lose a tempo we have Queen to
f5 now and this is how stock again makes
room for the e6 pawn to be pushed
forward while attacking the knight on f3
so it's without wasting time Bishop to
e2 and now II 6 making room for the dark
square bishop to enter the game
we have h3 and now Bishop captures on f3
we have Bishop characters and c6 now as
there is a threat of Bishop characters
on b7 so c6 and Queen to e2 making room
for a queen-sized castle if you've seen
the previous game both stop wishing the
Lea decided it's better to Castle
queenside against the Scandinavian saw
something definitely to consider we have
Knight B to d7 and a queenside castle
now stalkerish goes for Bishop to b4 of
course wanting to capture and c3 to mess
up well II lost bone structure on the
Queen side and better back to d2 we have
castles bye-bye stockfish and now King
Derby one a nice prophylactic move at
some point Queen a5 is coming so you
might want to worry about this and Queen
captures on a2 so the King nicely
defended but still Queen to a5 by
stockfish and now
a3 asking do you want to retreat with
the bishop or maybe do something else
the problem is if you retreat with
something like Bishop to e7
then even ideas like a Knights to d5
become possible and the white will
always be able to pick off this this
Bishop here since you opened up the
discovery and once the Queen moves you
can pick off the Bishop on e7 so here at
Bishop captures and c3 right away Levi
recaptures and now Queen back to c7 so
this is a what stuff is got out of the
opening out of the Queen to d6
Scandinavian intact pawn structure there
nothing really going on here but it's
two knights against the allele as a
bishop pair so if you know how little I
usually plays you know this could be an
issue
and here Lila starts pushing on the King
side which of course makes sense we have
Knight to d5 centralizing the knight
also making
room for the other nights to come to f6
while attacking the bishop on c3 so
Bishop back to d2
Lilla not interested in parting with the
bishop pair and now b5 stock which wants
to start attacking on the Queen side now
with h5 and Queen to b6 now putting
pressure on the d4 pawn and now h6 and
now well you you might consider grabbing
here at the pawn on d4 and allowing H
garrison g7 is just not possible
so here g6 of course blocking this and
now kinked a1 again
just a nice nice useful move at some
point Knight to c3 might come with check
so you want to avoid this as well
and here again you're asking are you may
be interested in a pawn here but again
capturing it now puts the Queen in front
of the rook so IDs like Bishop to b4
come to mind the Queen is under attack
of the rook is under attack so not not
really something you want to do so after
King a one we have rook F to b8 now
getting the rook away from f8 but now c3
just defending that d4 pawn queen back
to d8 and now stop which is definitely
ready to start pushing
pawns here and now bishop the c1 opening
up the rook and also the bishop will
help out with the defense of the Queen
side pawns with a 5 and now comes c4
Lila decides that if the position is
going to open up is gonna open up under
her terms
so be characters with Queen captures on
c4 and now Queen to f6 putting pressure
on the bishop here we have Bishop to c4
and now comes Luke the c8 you could also
capture on f2 but stockfish doesn't want
to give Leo at the semi open F file to
use for the attack it could be could be
dangerous another thing why this better
appear is very useful so for example
Queen captures does not come with the
threat of checkmate as the roof is also
attacking the pawn here chakra decides
against it we have looked the c8
protects the c6 pawn instead and the
Queen back to E - now now defending the
f2 pawn we have Knight 7 to b6 now
and g4 we have rook a to b 8
now aligning this rook with with the
b-pawn and now comes Luke ht1 just
getting the other look into the game
problem is if you play rook h2f 1
preparing f4 which is definitely what
you want to do then black can block it
with Knight to f4 and then if you attack
it again like the Queen d2 then the
other night comes to d5 so you've you
you weren't able in executing f4 so here
Leah and still goes rook to e1 waits for
stockfish to make a move which stockfish
does and a stop which goes for Knight to
d7 again I repeat some with the night
maybe with the idea of playing c5 at
some point but now it is possible to go
rook to f1 and now probably if stockfish
would repeatedly level to repeat and
then look for something else but
Stockbridge doesn't and also Knight to
f4 here isn't all that great now because
after Queen d2 there's a double attack
on the night and you don't have a knight
and b6 to come to d5 to help out with
the defense here so once this Knight
moves now you will be able to execute f4
so instead after rook f1 stop which
doesn't repeat instead we have Queen to
e7 and Queen to e7 and now f4 just
pushing the point we have worked yet and
now Queen to f3
now with ideas of maybe even busting
open with f5 we have night seventh to f6
putting pressure on the bishop sorry
Knight 7 to have six putting pressure on
the bishop and the bishop goes back to
be one so both bishops nicely tucked in
for later and a4 we have brush up to a
to putting the bishop on the the King's
diagonal so f5 will open up some some
threats definitely so King the h8 and
now rook to f2 allele and now prepares
rook to c2 again go after the c6 pawn
but also prevents e5 we look beat the c8
preparing to push c5 and now rook the c2
here we have Queen to d7 and now comes
Bishop to d2 just improving the position
as much as possible keeping an eye on
all of the squares that this night can
go to King back to g8 and now even g5
and here
now you can see that Lila is not trying
to open up open up files on the kingside
but rather really just constricting the
movement of all of the pieces that
doctor says here Stopford goes Knight to
the h5 has no other square is available
and now you will constantly have
problems once this Queen reaches let's
say a five and threatens Queen g7
checkmate this Knight is stuck here for
the rest of the game and it will not be
easy here
Lila goes rook the c4 just improves the
position keeps an eye on the pawn
attacks the e4 pawn so Queen to a7
defending the e4 pawn and now rugby to
see one puts more pressure on c6 we have
rook to b8 currently you cannot capture
because you would also lose the d4 pawn
so Queen to f2 improving again the
position that everything is nicely
defended the Queen guards d4 Queen and
Bishop Gardea for pawn so black has to
figure out what to do here we have
Knight back to e7 and now comes bishop
the back to be one if Knight a5 you
could you could even capture it we have
Queen - b7 threatening made here and now
push back to be for just the defending
against mate and now Queen to see 795
going after the bishop here runs into
Bishop d6 just kicks away the rook and
there is no checkmate because the Queen
now again guards against mate once the
bishop moved from from d2 so after
Bishop b4 we have Queen to c7 now puts
again more pressure on f4 and Bishop
back to d2 just defending it we have
rookie back to c8 and now Bishop to c4
now with a triple attack on the c6 pawn
we have Queen to d7 and now finally rook
captures an a4 yeah it would be
impossible to defend for example even if
even if instead of this rook here you
went for Queen to a7 again to defend the
pawn you could always win a good brush
up the c2 so stock here doesn't even try
after Bishop d2 like I said rook e8 rook
eat the c8 Bishop to b4 now I with a
triple attack here not in a rush to win
the pawn as like we've shown you you
cannot defend it Queen to d7 and now
look at for Sunday for Leela grabs upon
with stockfish not really having any any
moves to gain any activity so nice to d5
button bunch of characters on d5 Queen
captures and now quinta III with ideas
of Queen to e5 we have Queen to d7 and
now rook rook a back to c4 again putting
pressure on the pawn here we look to be
five and now rook the c5 offering a
trade here white would be very happy to
do so as little eyes up upon the Kings
have completely locked off this Knight
cannot enter the game so would be every
rookie trade basically you will be left
up a piece as this Knight cannot move so
rugby to b8 sorry unless Roxy to be a
true B to b8 getting the road back not
allowing the trade and now Queen e5 and
we reach this position where like I said
this knife cannot move because of
checkmate but also there's the threat of
just rook captures and c6 and once the
route captures you will pick up the the
rook on b8 so look the aah doctor
doesn't allow this and now rook one to
c4 just increasing the activity of the
rooks now controlling everything but
also Oliva is now ready to push the past
a point which seems crazy since it's
it's kind of black who's trying to
attack on the Queen side but if it works
why not so look the a6 buy stock fish
and now look the B for not allowing
stock fish the use of the B file we have
rook a back to a 8 and now King Tubby 1
you want to get your King away from the
a file if you are attending to push the
a pawn so rook the d8 putting some
pressure here but not really irrelevant
since the deposition is completely
guarded everything is beautifully
guarded and starfish can cannot make a
move here we have a 4 here and now rook
back to f8 here a stock which wants to
play f6 a hope for a capture and then
the knight finally gets back into the
game and while that is happening lila
continues pushing on the Queen side we
have a 5 and now finally f6 we have
captures Knight captures finally the
knight re-enters the game and now rook
beat the c4 again puts pressure on the
c6 pawn with Knight to g4 attacking
the Queen and now Queen back to e4 we
have Knight characters on h6 grabbing
that pawn which is a huge deal for black
but then again you know white is the one
who starts grabbing pawns rook captures
we have Knight to f5 and now Queen
captures on e6 with check we have Queen
captures and rook captures and here we
have this position where Lila is up two
pawns and well to make matters worse
three of three of those four points are
passed pawns so rook F to d8 attacking
the pawn and Bishop the c3 nicely yeah
solidifying king f7 attacking the rook
rook back to e one we have looked at d7
and now b4 and now those two connected
passed pawns are really a force to be
reckoned with
we have Knight to e7 and now look the h1
goes after the H point we have h5 and
King b2 of course you have to bring your
King into the game as well Knight to d5
attacking the bishop bishop back to d2
keeping an eye on everything
rook to b7 now with pressure on the
before ponen King III getting the King
away from the B file we have Knight back
the e7 and now if you had this position
or pretty much anyone you would probably
look for ways to improve your position
with something like King a for it maybe
would play rook c5 maybe you'd try to
get the other work into the game but not
illegal allele it decides to show off
and leave a place f5 and the point is if
you capture of course you lose the H
pawn but if the knight captures what
Lila did here is that she opened up the
F file for the rook and yes chess is
that simple obviously you give up a pawn
in an endgame for an open file so just
King gave for continuing like nothing
happened and okay nice 2d6 attacks the
rook but now rook the c6 attacks the
knight Knight to c8 and now comes rope
the f1 with check the knight is position
on c8 so the knight wants to come to a 7
at some point you will have to defend
the g6 pawn we have King g7 getting out
of check and rook g1 now both of the
rooks attack at the logistics pond so
Knight to e7 with a double attack
defending an attack
look back to c5 and now rook to d7
attacking the pawn here and now rook
captures an h5 it's interesting that
stockfish didn't even try to defend
against this with something like Inc -
h7 but obviously obviously stockfish
knows that if the King goes all the way
back here that these passed pawns are
just completely dominant so try
something else
rook the d7 we have rook captures on h5
of course you cannot capture due to the
pin and now black cannot capture because
of - of the c3 so you're not even
winning that pawn so rook to b8 and now
comes Luke H to g5 puts more pressure on
the g6 pawn king f7 and now rook to f1
with check King g8 and rook to g4 now
defending the pawn here we have looked
the d5 and now Bishop the c3 just
defending both of the pawns and ugly
square for the bishop yes for the moment
it does appear to be a pawn but it's
only for the moment King g7 and now look
back to e4 going after the night here we
have looked the b7 defending and now
rook to h4 we have Knight to a5 with
with an attack on the rook and the pawn
and rook the h3 point is the point can
never be captured because you just you
just attack and rook F for the the pin
is still existent and after let's say
defense and now you attack it once again
and again you you win material in the
game so after rook h3 William g5
starfish starts pushing the past pawn
but rook the g1 goes after the g5 pawn
we have came to g6 and now rook the h8
we have roped the c7 going after the
bishop and the bishop to beat you now we
have Knight to e7 now also again if you
go for night characters on d4 it's
possible but it only ends up in a loss
Ruby g8 check and after the King moves
and now you play rook captures on g5 and
once wrote captures you're gonna play
Bishop captures on d4 with check King
somewhere captures captures and yes
you've won back the exchange but the two
past points will of course win against
the roof even probably even without the
bishop so after Bishop b2 we have night
the e7 a stop fishes out of options here
and now rook the c1 offering a trade
rook d7 of course declining and now rook
to e1 again not leaving starfish marshal
much options King g7 goes after the rook
rook h2 we have King to g6 and rook to
g2 now and rook to e7 so Bishop to see
one again puts pressure on the g5 pawn
look the f5 and now just a beautiful
rook captures and g5 you could just
improve your position even further with
rookie g1 but Leela says it's not
important like in the previous game that
we've shown Leela doesn't mind giving up
a piece for no reason to make the
position simpler but also winning point
is that after characters and captures
stockfish decided not to capture the
bishop because capturing the bishop just
runs into b5 and like I said the two
points are simply too strong whatever
you play you're getting a six and now
after King f5 you're gonna get rook c5
check completely cut the King off from
the game King a5 and now you're just
gonna bring the King in and win the game
king b6 okay night-night c8 check you
have to go back King to see 637 check
now you're gonna go king c5 and now
there is no defense whatever you play
just b6 and and that's just it if you
play route characters here b7 there's no
there's no way to stop promotion if you
try rook to b6 then of course just
captures night with check and otherwise
just captures or bb-8 is promoting a
queen inter game and winning so stock
which doesn't even capture the bishop
doctor she instead goes Knight to d5 and
here we have looked the e5 Knight to c3
check came to b3 in the Knights to d1 we
have keen to see two attacking the
knight further knife to f2 and now
Bishop to h4 again harassing the knight
Knight h3 and rook to e7 now forcing the
rook somewhere else
rook to a6 and now finally King b3 now
the king as the knight is now safely
away the King will make its way into the
game and of course well hopefully win
not a for King c4 we have looked the a 8
and now Bishop
to g3 again harassing the night rook c8
check we have King to b5 and now Knight
to d5 we have Brooke to d7 app pushes
the knight back Knight c3 Trek and the
King b6 we have looked the c4 goes after
the pond but a nice Bishop to e1 saying
that if you capture the if you capture
the pawn then just King here and now
both of your pieces are under attack and
you don't have you don't have many
options here if rook to b3 you're just
gonna go King to c4 and once you move
rook III just capture that in that piece
so after Bishop e1 we have knight back
the b1 and now comes Luke the c7 a nice
tricky move by Leela forcing a forcing
the roof to capture the pawn but now
comes of course well any move wins here
but now Leela instead of a 6 to be
consistent in her philosophy it goes
after the piece now comes Luke to c1 and
okay now the night is almost wrapped you
could go to a three but it wouldn't
really make sense because after a six
night c4 check you just pick up the
night and you continue pushing just a
seven and that's it the B point is
nicely protected so after Luke's t1
stalk which again doesn't even try to
save the night everybody ate but now
rook captures and b1 and here a few more
moves were played rule d6 checking c5 we
have looked east six King defy sorry
King d5 rook to a6 here
b5 was played not even worrying about
the a 5.0 sorry I didn't see from the
microphone I didn't see that the bishop
was guarding it really really weird
positioning rook the a8 and now b6 and
it was finally on this move
113 that stockfish resigned the game so
as you can see both Leela and stock
which one they're respectable games in
the Queen to d6 Scandinavian so although
this is a it sounds like bad news for
the Queen d6 cannon even players but
it's not really no one would ever play
the way the the engine's plate and both
Leela's move that pawn to e6 and the
stockers Queen to e6 check I have never
been played in human chess so either
humans don't
know how to play the Queen d6
Scandinavian or the engine just think
that the way humans play it is is bad
and they don't even want to go into it
either way I will still continue to play
it and most likely others will so now as
it is a very enjoyable opening but I'm
very happy that it seems that it's bad
both tactically and positionally stocks
we should destroy Leela in a tactical
frenzy and Leela created this beautiful
positional masterpiece where a stock
wish couldn't move a single pawn or
piece for the entire game
so now you know do play the Scandinavian
yeah like I said that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I don't know if
you've seen on my community tab I will
start a tournament on leaches every
Friday I made a poll for you to vote it
I will make put the poll in the
description below first thing you will
see if you want to vote on the time
format I've been deciding between bullet
and blitz a 1 plus or 3 plus so but
since all so many of you already voted 3
plus so I think we're gonna go with the
3 plus so and more in more information
on that soon so if you haven't seen it
you want to drop your vote check it out
in the description so once again I do
hope you enjoyed the game I would like
to thank will enable you for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos you're
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga coverage of the TCC super finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world and I have a very
special game prepared for tomorrow it
goes into the sorcery series yes you've
heard that correctly so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day